Why is Free Speech so important as a
principle because if that's not your
principle then inherently you're saying
that there should be someone else who
decides what you can and cannot say and
there's nothing to me that's scarier
than that I mean and I'm somebody who
it's like I've never been the target of
hateful speech I mean I get some of the
most disgusting stuff directed at me
every day like whether it's mean or
whether it's deeply kinky sexual from
men who you look at their Instagram and
it's like a picture of them with their
grandkids yeah like okay does your wife
know you're on here you sick [__]
um
I have my with the exception of Anthony
Weiner probably not right right probably
not and but to me it's like when people
say okay what about this speech and what
about this speech and then my question
to those people always is okay well then
who would you like to see making that
decision it drove me nuts throughout the
entire Trump presidency how many people
would call for hate speech laws but then
also say that Trump is literally Hitler
so how can you have those two views at
the same time so you want the government
to be controlling speech the same
government that you yourself just said
you think the figurehead or you know the
head of the Executive Branch is
literally Hitler and you don't see how
those two don't make sense together if
anything the people who really hated
Trump and thought he was Hitler should
have came out of that presidency more
free more for Free Speech but that's
just not how it worked out so what about
um you know you in the book you you run
through a bunch of different examples of
people who got pilloried for bad speech
uh Kathy Griffin is yeah
who I actually I'm a big fan of I think
she's very funny I think my life on the
d-list was great but she as I think the
audience will remember she got in big
trouble including bounce off of Twitter
but then put on a no-fly list and was
being harassed by the TSA and by the
government for having done a kind of
stupid stunt where she had a kind of
mannequin head of trump a severed head
et cetera you defended Her speech
um how did and that must have been hard
at a fox in a fox context right I did I
wrote a column about it for National
Review at the time and because at the
time there was people I mean it was a
pretty common take on conservative
Twitter that she should be you know
executed for this and like you said
we're talking about nobody really
thought no sane person really thought
that the star of My Life on the d-list
as you mentioned was actually planning
to assassinate the president so I think
that you could say you thought it was
gross you could say you didn't like it
but saying that it's not protected
speech is that's a super dangerous take
in my opinion especially because we are
talking about Kathy Griffin she made a
career being I mean when she wanted Emmy
she got up there and said I think
something like suck it Jesus this award
is my God now something along those
lines I quoted it directly in my book
but we can't really be shocked that she
did something like this and again the
conservatives a lot of them who consider
themselves Free Speech said okay but
this should be prosecuted it's like well
no because the first amendment is the
main purpose of it is to criticize
people in power without government
retaliation as a check on the government
so I don't care how you feel about it
you have to stand against it to make
sure that that's never used against you
in the future so one of the other things
you talk about because they're you know
I and I think most of the people in this
audience probably are like okay yeah
speech shouldn't be banned but then
maybe certain types of speech should be
disapproved of in such a way it's almost
the same as Banning it or one of the
examples that you talk about in your
book
um is blackface in old TV actually not
even old TV shows we're not talking
about Amos and Andy but we're you know
relatively recent sketch comedy right
where when these shows go up on places
like Hulu or Netflix or whatever they've
pulled the uh episodes that deal in
blackface even though without exception
it's a critique of the world that gave
us blackface but talk a little bit about
why you know I've I'm blanking on the
exact title of the chapter right now but
it's something like nothing should ever
disappear yeah don't erase anything yeah
right including blackface yeah in the
summer of 2020 they they called it I
think the New Yorker wrote a piece
called like you know this
saying how many different streaming
services pulled episodes of things I
mean there are different series I mean
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia 30
Rock
um How I Met Your Mother there was there
was so many different episodes the
interesting thing about how I met your
mother was there was somebody who is
more on the left who I her name I don't
remember it's in the book who was saying
you know we shouldn't erase anything
because then we can't talk about it we
can't have that conversation and I agree
with that but the example that she gave
was the yellow face uh episode of How I
Met Your Mother where they sort of
dressed up as you know Kung Fu Masters
and there was this debate at the time of
is this yellow face is this just
silliness but she actually got the
character wrong that was actually
dressed like that because it's a lot
harder to have those conversations when
it doesn't exist anymore and the past
you know it's it happened whether you
acknowledge it or not and there's no
purpose for wanting to erase things
except for wanting to delude it's kind
of the same thing as if you don't like
how your life is going you want to go
out and get [__] up and forget all
about it that doesn't mean that your
life's any better it means you're just
ignoring it and it's always better to
have more information rather than less
and that doesn't even count the time
that you get [__] up and then do
blackface yeah yeah true yeah
which you uh I want to point out in the
book she says that she has never done
blackface no so you should be saying all
of her social future well I mean you
know we live in a time where within
recent memory there was this great
moment where the governor of Virginia uh
Ralph Northam or the ex-governor of
Virginia was shown to he was either in
blackface or in a cake
in his medical Medical School yearbook
yes no yeah I've never done blackberries
there is my I write about this in my
book too I'll mention this book I was a
black Labrador Retriever for Halloween
when I was a child because my cousin had
a lab retriever there is an
uncomfortable photo of me with like when
I took the ears off but yeah
my brother was like I'm Gonna Cancel
like I'm like six years old maybe you
know you don't even know what that is
but I was Pocahontas for Halloween when
I was like seven what I know
what about you also talk about Roseanne
Barr who who now this I mean it's
interesting because this again isn't
legal prohibitions but then there's you
know questions about okay how does
society organize what is acceptable and
what is not Roseanne Barr who mounted
what you know hands down the most
successful rebooting comeback in in
recent TV history where uh you know the
new Roseanne show was a massive off the
charts hit that hadn't been seen in
decades really
um and then she tweeted out you know
objectively racist stuff about a a
Barack Obama advisor
um and that's it um what's your take on
that broader kind of uh moment because
she I mean it was a twit a tweet which
she later said I was you know on ambient
of other things which I don't know I
take ambient almost every night and my
Twitter feed never Rises to that level
yeah that's that never happened to me
yeah so what what should happen in that
case is that not simply you know the the
Vox public I don't know the public voice
the voice of the people saying you know
what we don't want that kind of person
in our life anymore you don't have to
have any kind of person in your life
that you don't want to have in your life
I think that Roseanne what she's a very
interesting example of is just how much
you know Twitter is pretty much never
worth it you know it's it's like you not
only do you not get paid but you also
can maybe get fired but it's the
I mean think of how much like every
stupid thing most of us have ever done
has been ultimately because of dopamine
what you know I mean it makes you do
dumb stuff because it feels good I'm
gonna say that for me it was really
alcoholic alcohol and cocaine but yeah
dopamine's in the top five
um you know you're better off not
drinking I love that uh but but also you
alcohol part of that is because of
dopamine right that's part of why people
seek out alcohol she had everything
going for her but she still couldn't
resist this one thing I also think that
what's the point and Sarah Silverman
said something about this once what's
the point of being a progressive if you
can't allow for Progress she actually
was speaking in the context of a friend
of hers who used to be a literal Nazi
not the way people say literal Nazi now
but like an actual Nazi who now realizes
how disgusting that is and since I was
looking for the you know if you if you
can't progress and if you can't learn
from mistakes and you're just canceled
forever then what are any of us even
doing here what are any of us doing
anywhere in trying to educate people or
in trying to express our beliefs or say
this is why this is I think this is
wrong and this is how I feel if it
doesn't matter anyway right
um we're going to talk about the roots
of your libertarianess
um in a bit but I mean you're very
libertarian but then I'm also thinking
you you treat this in the book uh
goddess about a decade ago whenever
Fukushima was Gilbert Gottfried a very
uh funny comedian who I think has is
dead right he is effective he is not
just figuratively dead he's literally
dead but after the Fukushima uh nuclear
power plant explosion uh he was the
voice of the Aflac duck which was you
know kind of a great gig right nobody
wants to lose that and he made a bunch
of jokes you know that were completely
in keeping with his public career and
Persona about uh Fukushima and he got
bounce from Affleck
um you would say definitely that's
within Affleck's rights to say we want
to distance ourselves but is that a do
you I mean do you think that's a good
decision no because especially for a
professional comedian when it couldn't
be more clear what your job is I mean he
was making a joke about a tragedy to try
to lighten it up it's not like he was
making the joke because he's like [__]
you Japan I don't care I mean that's
that's like if you're firing somebody
that's probably what you would be
thinking but you nobody actually thinks
that you know and he was so synonymous
that whenever you see that duck you hear
the voice in your head regardless of the
fact that he was canceled and then he
died it is the job of comedians to make
jokes about things that are dark and
um we shouldn't be canceling them for
doing that I think that intention is
what should matter there's this really
dumb idea out there now and people
actually say this if it's someone says
they're offended that's all that matters
full stop attention doesn't matter but
how stupid is that of course intention
matters of course it matters whether or
not somebody was you know saying I'm
trying to make this joke here because
I'm a comedian or whether someone's
saying I'm making this joke because I
like that that natural disaster killed
all those people [__] those people
then that firing and that [__] you would
be completely and and much more would be
completely appropriate right but there
is that difference we all know that and
it's dumb to pretend that we don't is
there a moment where like intention just
kind of flew out the window and you know
was there a time when you know people
are like okay we're gonna look you know
at somebody says something that is
considered awful or beyond the pale and
but we're going to look at it
holistically or with intention I mean
clearly we don't tend to do that now you
know what what what do you think has
contributed to the idea people on the
right and the left
um you know are just like ready to
pounce whenever why is that I think that
it's tribalism and I think that it's
fear I think that people are afraid of
being canceled for sure I think that
it's also easy to pile on a Twitter for
example if someone's getting canceled
you don't have to actually face that
person when they get fired you don't
have to get up off the toilet you just
sit there and say like wow quote tweet
it or this you know or something yeah
and like and then you're like I'm one of
the good ones you know and if you have a
side there's certain sacred cows on your
side that you need to show that you you
know see as sacred or else you might be
jeopardizing your place on that side and
I think social media also makes that
worse because
um you know you you get to see all these
people telling you [__] you when
normally you wouldn't get to see that
and also because studies show that on at
least Twitter and Facebook they're you
know historically moral emotional words
and grandstanding they get more
engagement than other posts which think
about how different that is from real
life right if you had a friend who would
only like talk like that you wouldn't
want to hang out with them anymore but
on social media it's actually rewarded